wildfires don't discriminate be it
Forest Farm or family homes like these
Northwest of Athens Greece is no
stranger to hot fiery Summers but
they're getting hotter the fires more
intense
the Flames were such that in 20 minutes
they had gone up the mountain and come
down again in 20 minutes
it's the first time in my life I've seen
such a thing
cleaning ash from her front steps elpida
parrotsidi was lucky to be left with her
home west of the capital
two days it was burning and not one fire
engine came
no one from the municipality look at
this mess
residents who'd fled Villages near the
town of mandra found little to pick
through on their return the constantly
Changing Winds meant a spark could flare
at any moment
everything is burned everything I will
throw it away it's all waste the boiler
burn
it melted
elsewhere the Flames are unrelenting
what else to do but pray
nuns at the gorgo piku's Convent in
Mundra are resisting police attempts to
evacuate
the Greek meteorological service is
warning of a second Heat Wave later in
the week and Greece of course is not
alone countries across the southern
Mediterranean and the Balkans have all
seen record temperatures in recent days
while many can take to the beaches for
Relief the vulnerable find it harder to
escape
in Rome with the temperature past 40
degrees celsius Medics are making house
calls on the elderly and the housebound
these people are afraid they won't make
it through they're afraid they won't be
able to go out
an estimated 61 000 people died in heat
waves last year in Europe alone a number
of Public Health authorities fear could
rise Jonah Al Jazeera